concorde le plus prestigieux et le plus
beau produit de la technologie franco
britannique de l'aviation le plus cher
aussi continuera à voler ainsi en ont
décidé les pouvoirs publics français
jean claude renaud feu vert pour une
année supplémentaire concorde continuera
l'an prochain d'assurer la liaison paris
new york
la seule encore exploités sous les
couleurs d'air france feu vert donc même
si le supersonique coûte environ 300
millions de francs par an aux
contribuables français
deux raisons ont incité le gouvernement
à ne pas le clouer au sol
la première c'est que concorde attire
plus de passagers qu'il y a un an
son coefficient de remplissage approche
et 60% à partir desquels l'avion devient
renta pourtant malgré un dollar en forte
hausse
les passagers sont moins nombreux au
départ de new york que de roissy il faut
dire que l'aller-retour coûte 22 mille
francs à paris et 33 mille francs à new
york
le gouvernement a une deuxième raison de
ne pas arrêter concorde
car la france et la grande-bretagne se
partagent les frais financiers engagés
au moment de la construction par exemple
le remboursement des emprunts du
programme supersonique
or le premier pays qui remisera concorde
dans un hangar devra payer la part de
son partenaire
c'est un argument dissuasif que les
anglais ont eux aussi très bien compris
puisque british airways continue de
relier londres et washington par
concorde et envisage même prolonger la
ligne
jusqu'à miami